welcome to this video playing Jay wolf
from France in this fat in minute game
ok probably you get a perk defense ok ok
I'm going to play this line with Bishop
e3 and now is it here h3 yeah I think so
this is an interesting line I recently
discovered I mean no I did invent it I
mean I found that this seems to be quite
interesting and one reason is that beef
fibers actually not do it because of
each five at least that's what I read ok
let's see what happens interesting yeah
we just winning a pawn yeah or not I
take you seven now just upon ya can just
take care so why does what has an extra
power now for no one for no particular
compensation yeah interesting i wonder
if i should play Queenie to just yeah
why not actually deserve an easy easy
move push up a six there is c4 so this
does not lead to much and yeah the
bishop is hanging on age six he needs to
do something Bishop g7 maybe just
retweeting but then i can play Bishop g5
and actually exchanged Queens yeah
that's quite good we need to was not the
only only move but should be should be
quite promising actually
ok so we captured don't mind the Queen's
right here after pawn takes I mean the
pawn structure is a bit weak with Queens
on so the trade is really welcome if he
avoids it with Bishop e6 I can just
develop an idea three Bishop d3 castles
now I expect him to trade only three
trying to try to hold this
yeah Oh page OB should be six there are
no other moves really ok this one um
yeah I can probably just take and play
kingly to win yeah that's the easiest
they are quickly tried for Knight f3
Bishop our droopy one what I need to
avoid is that black sets up a blockade
on the seafloor square especially in a
situation where the pawn is not on d5 so
something like that same if black can
move for 10 times in row night d 7b six
Bishop e6 Bishop c4 Bishop trades Knight
to c4 this this would be very
uncomfortable having a night on c4 that
cannot be expelled but I can just play
Knight f3 we should be three rocky one
likes not managing that if the light
arrives on b6 there is also see form to
be considered just occupying this square
with the pawn
yeah but the nice should be okay on a 30
k h6 is a slightly mysterious didn't
really intend to play 95 @ @ any any
point but okay certainly a play will
move okay I don't mind the trade if what
if he trades and I could take with the
pawn there is no danger anymore of
something arriving on c4 this is just a
strengthening off the porn structure and
if black retreats ability Bishop to e6
at least I've gained yeah almost I've
gained a tempo here with Bishop d3 the
question is after there should be six if
i should play see form or maybe Knight
b6 is really a really a problem i don't
know and i can first first wait what I
black is doing it might be a completely
different booths like here getting the
King to f6 it's quite surprising yeah
obviously wants to recapture with the
King on f5 if I if I take on f5 he will
play King takes quite remarkable okay
maybe I should prepare that if like a
now play some yeah something besides
that I mean and then I could have taken
play rookie seven okay here i can take
only aid and play rook be 10 it says
something better here even
I'll rupee one is not bad after rookie
one lucky one this should be fine point
them also introducing the idea to take
only eight and play rugby seven yeah
whether there should be many many decent
moves but it's not so easy to determine
the best one yeah I'm actually wondering
if I should take with the night trying
to relocate this piece whenever three
it's not doing much really it looks at a
five ng five which is both covered but
the night only one is also not great
does not have any great destination
squares yeah taking with the king I rook
takes is also be should be six okay I'll
take what the king I really not sure
check okay so should I go see for now or
is there a big big problem with that
there should be six can always be a bit
tricky yeah the night is really not well
placed on f3 it would be nice on III
actually maybe I can get the night to
III somehow night and night h2 now this
Bishop e6 possibly attacking the a pawn
hmm
if i take on a five King takes King d3
intending see form ID place d5 maybe i
can go nitey five them
yeah I'm not totally sure how to play
that there is also maybe Luke be 3 a-3
could be an idea this is actually
something that i like getting the rook
to a3 the rook is also not doing much at
the moment on b1 rook a three maybe rook
a5 the scan this keeps some pressure on
the on the pawn here and the root can
maybe go to a five later and also if I
go see for at some point at Bishop b6 I
might have King to c3 covering this
without night a for coming yeah this is
quite okay yeah okay seems like seems
like a playable option still I would get
like to get the night 223 yeah here he
is maybe I maybe can play em that's
actually true maybe you can play 94 hand
after if after i take Bishop takes and
there is a rookie to threatened hmm yeah
that's not good
okay maybe maybe still this night c4 I
take Bishop takes Knight g4 check 93
should be fine and if you go something
like h5 a plane i def one and then two
III only three the night is doing two
things that control it's the crucial
square c4 and d5 and it blocks the
e-file so that the rukon e7 cannot
invade I probably didn't play this so
great but it's still so should be fine I
believe yeah I would have liked to play
something like age 4 against age 5 but I
didn't have the time to do that I needed
to address this issue here first but
this should be nice now actually wears
black going with the Bishop Bishop b5
the c-4 Bishop a 6 is hanging so if he
needs to go to e6 basically and then I
play rook a6 attacking the C porn and
the a pond at the same time if he goes
Luke c7 there is C form and this is this
is not very comfortable okay okay is 60
is this is this not doing so much
running I cannot do much anyway really i
go here first fixing some more pawns on
light squares this is some a good
strategic move maybe yeah if he goes
jihad I playbook a5 this rook a6 he will
play rook c7 and possibly Bishop c8
later expel Marik it's not bad but it's
not really am
helping me such a great deal really I'm
not sure where this Bishop is going if I
go here now
yeah the question is what about d5 here
trying to immediately decide decide
matters at d5 could be very good
actually input now Bishop d7 probably
it's probably winning but I don't need
to rush anything here the I don't I
don't like to to to force matters here
early i can i can easily improve my
position further i have a good structure
here and they still have the opportunity
to play C for King see three maybe even
see five this could be strategically
also very problematic for black if I
just push the pawn to c5 you cannot
really trade as then my pawn structure
will be straightened out and yeah after
c4 c5 d 5 which is terribly passive so
I'd like to play this little bit slower
slower fashion there is no need to rush
things yeah another weakness okay so
should I go see for ya
he might intend to play Ruby 7 and
activating this maybe I should get in
rugby three brooke be three to be six or
B's vp8 bishop e6 i can place your form
to still have b3 available for the rook
yeah it should be okay
the night is really perfectly placed on
e3 is what was I believe a good maneuver
getting it down it controls all the
important square C 4 D 5 f-5 that's very
often in fact the right term night
placement against the bishop placing it
on the opposite colored square like here
on a dark square to control the light
squares here we have a case where the
night is almost dominating the bishop
the bishop only six sort of you're
looking at the same square c4d file frg
forward in this case the night is the
dominating piece in a way because black
can never move to the bishop to any of
those squares so I'm very good a good
post for this piece yeah now he's not
coming up with the move it is very
difficult I just plan rook be three to
be six okay yeah not quite sure what
this is doing but I'm going to do this
anyway there should be six rook b6 ya
know I can can just trade ropes but
there is no need to do it right now I
can improve a bit
yeah yeah this is an interesting
question after a five I can consider to
play a four actually trying to to win
this pawn on e5 because while it's on a
dark square so it's a very tricky to to
be defended by black I can also i wonder
i can actually just take him this is
this is the easiest i believe and now f4
to prevent any g5 ideas okay g5 was not
dangerous but still and now the next
step here is to try to get the king over
to a form and just win the pawn i could
also try to get the pawn with the night
maneuver maneuvering the night to be
three like g to e 1 d 3 c1 be three
butts okay you see that it takes quite a
long while and in the meantime black
would get counter play against the King
side so i'm using my king for that
that's the much easier way to do it so
here i should invest the smooth
preventing c65 this actually threatens
night c4 at some point so the question
is if black can can even take em
yeah it's easiest to to take now okay
night c4 takes a 5 as the the simplest
looking possibility the only question is
94 king d 595 q4 do i really want to
calculate this
generally don't know if I want to want
to calculate that or if there is some
some easier way to do this maybe King
b3c five otherwise this king air for
coming maybe this is the easiest c5 and
then I played d5 just establishing a
passer supported by C for later yeah
that's I can guess the easiest way to to
play that
maybe there were more forceful ways just
rubbing a five but this just kills all
counterplay
so let's consider how to how to how to
play it in the easiest easiest way um it
could be very nice to get the night over
to e4 with the check to win the c5 bond
so I'm night d12 III d 1 2 C 3 could be
an idea so there are something better
yeah I can also just get the King over
and play c5 it's not bad okay let's do
that they're real they're really are
many ways to win this now
there is also the move f5 just like that
pawn takes Knight g2f for h5 and Bishop
takes while we get a key and porn end
game with a protected pass on d5 so f5
is a playable moving in any case yeah
here I can also get the the night over
to be three yeah ok but i'll go for for
the King marched reform it seems like
the easiest easiest option
yeah no it's taking lots of time right
when it's really a really too late yeah
there is no no one particular defensive
idea that black has like and play okay
going over them yes though from age
three the bishop does not have any
spares the nidus mentioned is completely
controlling or critical spots f 1 f 5 so
I'm just going over here and tending to
play f5
yeah still there should be a five right
let's not even have a check yeah this
was the idea now g6 as a weakness so the
King can attack that I can regroup the
night to attack the weakness in fact if
I go King g5 there maybe is this this
idea with the King e5 this is in fact
easier night f1 d3z for winning the c5
pawn
check
hmm just briefly considering here that
I'm I take it we should be one now but
okay a three Bishop a to resent it is
just too much i also have king d6 king
e5 and e6 am coming yeah well he really
just gave away a pawn right in the
opening and never got it back I believe
that each age 3 here is almost
preventing b5 because of this e5 move
it's it's really annoying for black um
if black takes for example this is not
really great the night does not have a
good square something like that for
example feels very uncomfortable not
this did this is just a weak structure
with white having a space advantage and
the bishop not being terribly good on
evade um this does not seem too great
and what else is there black can retreat
but here I can just take and after the
recapture there is the most d5 and black
structures as falling apart I think b5
is just not good what he played is just
giving our pawn but there is no
compensation for it really we need to
yeah he could could have tried bishop a
six year but I was thinking just see
form and there is no no big point to
Black's play yeah took yeah now we got
got the endgame yeah I'm not quite sure
what's the what's the toughest defense
this is probably am strengthening my
structure even King here there should be
three possibly four I just not really
helped like okay you went for this yet
here it's a matter of the the correct
set up just to make it as easy as
possible
yeah maybe I could have taken you on a
five but I didn't really want to at the
moment and only here I recognize that it
is slightly slightly tricky okay now I
went for this rook lift the computer
does not like it at all interestingly
enough now and because of this move I
thought that hmm yeah I understand this
was my original intention but now that I
look at it this is not too great here
with this idea I need to retreat him and
now both pieces are silly yeah this is
what it should have done then the CERN
loses it moves really and here I'm just
in time for the night coming 23 and
after that I'm really winning i think
the night is some just completely
dominating this position yeah i played
it in a very a slower slow manner but it
was always very promising until a very
promising is very mud expression i think
white is flat-out winning TM yeah there
are many many moves i think that this
was actually a bit tougher but still it
should be pretty easy when the a porn is
exceptionally week as well if we
consider this for example white um can
go over here maybe regroup the night and
many ways to to win this yeah this this
way there was also night c4 but i wanted
to keep it as simple as possible and
this was just the way to play it without
having to calculate any serious line
just just a simple continuation can't
going over here and winning the seaport
yeah it was pretty
action opening catastrophe after which
black was in big trouble okay thanks for
watching